bonjour à tous bienvenue on est encore
aujourd'hui en suisse icher une histoire
par ailleurs je sais qu'il avait pas
trop conditions sont plutôt en suisse
aux pays de la gruyère je les ai tous
deux chez les helvètes ont douché les
veufs et aujourd'hui chez les helvètes
on va continuer à parler d'apple parce
qu'à une première vidéo d'ailleurs si
vous n'avez pas suivi le lien est juste
au dessus de la tronche de mr carrier
donc vous pouvez les voir parce qu'on
voyait déjà d'ailleurs je vous conseille
de couper cette vidéo d'éléments celle
là et après de revenir oui ça on prend
les choses boutabout on fait les choses
correctement comme on le fait chez les
suisses va il fait pas je les connais
faut être carré
il faut être très bref donc aujourd'hui
on va parler d'apple version numéro 2
dont on a déjà parlé de beaucoup de
produits d'apple maintenant on va
continuer un petit peu le voyage dans le
temps donc on va commencer à 3
bon steve jobs est tout triste tout
triste tout triste mais il est beaucoup
la musique ce cher steve il adore la
musique c'est un autre jeune fille
exactement
ouais il se dit moi toute cette musique
je la veux dans ma poche mais les mecs
ils le font déjà ils font des lecteurs
ebook monde des lecteurs mp3 voilà
exactement ce qu'on lit tous ces trucs
ils sont moches qui sont nos choix sont
moches ils passent pas déroger une poche
moi je veux un truc qui fonctionne avec
itunes parce qu'ils avaient lancé itunes
avant l'ipod un agent ue donc il s'est
dit moi je veux une synergie entre
itunes et un lecteur ouais
et attention canada 1 ne vous inquiétez
pas ça l'exhibitionniste alors là donc
là t'as l'iphone en 2001 michel hamy
cantalès à la ceinture
tyson gay est une rondelle tu étais dans
alors là mon pote et dans le game accord
tu sors ça ta poche ça c'est le tout
premier ipod toutes premières éponges
2001 accompagné de sa petite pochette en
cuir de vachette en cuir de vachette
anarchie match timide formidable donc là
on a quand même un truc qui est super ip
malgré tout mais parce que c'est le
disque à la place qu'il connaît le
disque et que les connectiques c'est
avec ses pas et ça c'est du firewire
c'était une connectique firewire énorme
la suite donc ça c'était tout pour les
miens pour
la wii et si tu voulais plus touchées le
mettez dans la poche sans une protection
à l'avocat la douche passe tous les
côtés ok donc l' écoute superbe objet
mais là c'est vrai que tu vois que tu es
camier on est sur un tout qui on a
vraiment changé depuis parce que vous ai
dis toi que dans la conception steve
jobs
donc il voulait quelque chose de petit
donc ils ont commencé par l'écran la
molette
ils ont fait plusieurs essais de molette
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que steve hill dix
bons coups pour celle ci donc le mec est
arrivé un des designers est arrivé donc
avec l'écran et la batterie ouais il
leur manquait une chose essentielle
c'était le disque dur il leur fallait un
tout petit disque dur et tu penses que
c'est qui qu'a fournie disque dur
foxconn
non je dois c'est un dragon philippe
lavaud répondait marque on en sort plus
beaucoup parler maintenant mais qui
était sur les disques durs à l'époque
ouais disque dur c'est une marque
japonaise
qui à l'époque était dans le guen
toshiba toshiba disques durs de 1,8
pouces apple a payé au choix que c'était
un million aux unions je ne sais plus et
c'était une grosse somme pour avoir
l'exclusivité de ce disque dur d'accord
ce chiffre le toshiba
je vous réponds d'aller quoi comme
capacité de stockage est dedans alors on
avait une capacité de 1000 chansons dans
la poche
c'était l'objectif le wild vendait pas
de l'espace disque il faudrait non au
nom de charles son mini chansons qui
sont fort en marketing and onta des
miseront la poche mais surtout c'était
la campagne de pub c'était ça et ils ont
fait une campagne de pub est morte avec
les stars t'avais movie et tout ça et
1000 chansons de musique de demain
[Musique]
non c'est ça ma ma musique énergie ce la
musique dans son big cherche t elle à un
verre marilyn monroe
donc voilà des choses liar liar
mérignies ou tourner dans le vide m'a
coûté tout c'est très beau
les systèmes hésitation merci de la
gorge
lol est en voyage dans le temps en
voyage aussi dans l'univers des goûts
musicaux qui ne sont pas les siens ok
donc ça 2001 autre truc essentiel
compatible qu'avec les ordinateurs apple
on communique avec la prise faille
encore ipod qui n'était pas encore là
cette époque c'est vrai il va paraître
après un très beau chouette merci merci
belle performance est-ce que tu connais
le haut vol le hotspot je connais où
elle est en pause il va bientôt sortir
en avril normalement royaume peu importe
qui va arriver en france
et là on a eu un poids de l'ancêtre de
l'homme paul hop hop hop hop hop donc ça
c'est mon pote des années 2000 six
manches 2006 donc ça c'est l'enceinte
d'apple l'ipod hi-fi l'ipod hi fi donc
ça veut dire qu'avant même côté des
petites enceintes dans lequel pourrait
plonger tourner ipod en modèle
miniaturisés apple avait sorti son truc
avec sa prise un peu propriétaire sur un
truc vraiment fait petit format petit
très discret d'accord vous dire que que
bose et les autres étaient déjà un petit
peu sur le marché
d'accord apple a voulu prendre le truc
même si ils vendaient leurs petits
connecteurs sur les trucs 1 et bien sûr
les accessoiristes doivent payer pour
avoir ce connecteur d'accord comme le
made for iphone de maintenance et l e
mail for ipod d'accord ok no te dire
qu'ils se sont faits des sceaux fait des
royalties pour fx monde voit look est
alors comment ça marche alors comment ça
marche
chérie tu comme passe à l'ipod est fort
il ya des assistants mais le parti ne
suis pas comment il fait ça c'est un
vrai talent en suisse donc là on a un
iphone grâce à une premier ipod qu'on
pouvait brancher dedans donc ça c'est
pas le premier premier avait pas le
petit connecteur ou les oublis tu as
raison il lui ressemble vraiment et là
on est à 40 gigant espace de stockage
là on est on est sur la marine sur l'a22
troisième version bim bim bim bam pas là
dedans
livré avec sa petite télécommande
infrarouge
bien sûr je vendais par le droit
d'auteur
[Musique]
donc vous pouvez voir la petite led ici
regarde un oui qui montre qu'on est en
train de bâtir agir avec d'accord et
choses bien sympathique
si on aime le design un peu plus 20
pages voilà et bien oui désolé mais je
dois y est je trouve sympa c'est
chouette le comme city voilà ça le décès
de la gueule oui et avec les satyres a
quand même wells en me forçant la liste
le son est beau quoi ouais et là sur eux
ils fournissent et aucune
aucun kilo watt de séisme dans l'aspect
qui nous mêmes le mode on sait pas
combien
combien il balance 2010 par exemple dans
le communiqué ensuite encore un truc
sympathique on a le volume
ici on a un audio in ici donc voilà
c'est situé sur les soirées karaoké tu
brancher un micro mon sens mais nous
nous y rendrons jamais tranché source
externe
ça veut dire ce qui est cool c'est que
celui ci si vous le retrouver qui est
assez rare
ouais mais vous le retrouvez vous
trouvez un petit jack bluetooth ouais et
ben bon de le rendre beau tout ça alors
qu'il était à bluetooth avait pas c'est
ça que j c ces mini jack avec bluetooth
tak tak très bon et alors là il ya un
truc qui me kim voilà tu peux le bruel
fermez là c'est quoi ça qu'est ce que
c'est ça cette vidéo est sponsorisé par
le recyclage des piles le recyclage de
plus c'est bien alors vas-y dis moi
qu'est ce que tu fais que ça pas les
piles bâtons qui lui permet depuis là
dedans alors ils aillent pas eu la bonne
idée de mettre une batterie voilà qui
aurait été super génial ouais non voilà
c'est sérieux un petit pas pour la
migros pas si ça va en france en famille
ce soir vous personne connaissant les
gens qui viennent en vacances en suisse
tout à fait et les suisses et les
suissesses vous êtes suisse si vous êtes
suisse par tout le monde en la
mélangeant commentaire parce que je je
me demande s'il ya beaucoup de personnes
en suisse qui regarde ma chaîne donc
voilà pour lui faire plaisir
moi qui me mentez mentez 10 des
cousettes je suis alors donc là que tu
voudrais tu mettais tout petit peu dans
l'exacte non à des six piles et c'était
une idée l'autonomie ou pas tout à fait
au mercy annoncé 10 heures par apple 10
heures déjà à 10h10 heure 10h ouais bah
je voulais déjà se lancer dans le string
mais on était plutôt vers 6-7 heures
donc abc7 en musique et tu passais en
gros tu passes une pipe à exactement la
musique août également l'alignement cher
oui c est pour se balader avec en mode
walkman sur l'épaule
ouais avec canon pour faire un peu
ghetto blaster tu vois
balade dans la rue ça c'est vraiment
très impressionnant machines hyper lourd
et à tapas et qu'il doit 6,6 kg 100 des
piles 7,6 avec magic comme foyer
dépourvu de syracuse année ensuite et tu
prêt mon cher a remis à laura soit
correctement c'est bien quand il parle
comme ça je suis prêt et tu prêt à voir
mon cher ami la plus belle pochette est
ce qu on dit chez nous bricoler une
pochette tu crois vraiment que tous les
thèmes que vous employez seconde étant
je suis en fait non pas du tout mais est
ce que vous dites four de mattel fonds
d'onatel non lors d'un tel symbole
cheyrou ouais on appelle ces téléphones
et l'otan ont dit non d'athènes jeudi ce
mois-là pasqua au québec c'est le
cellulaire cette cellule r cellulaire je
comprends mon natel ok donc la table
c'est chez vous minc alors donc pour
donner à tel nom nouveau chaton dit on
dit pochette
ok ok faut de natel c'est un étui c'est
une force très bizarre donc étui est tué
made in apple d'accord ok découvre cet
étui vend cher ami d'accord déjà tu as
vu que l'extérieur a pas très très bien
vieilli
il a quelques années quand même assez
normal oui si malgré tout ouais je
trouve que c'est pas trop tard tu poses
eagles a donc là jaloux rire en même
temps ensemble avant plus donc là je
suis sûr je suppose la bêtise il
semblera n'aille pas qu'est ce qu'il en
dit mr paris il en dit je suis pas six
mois avec ça le premier rail pass à ses
tout premiers ipad
ouais c'est à dire que tu as quand même
1 4 kim a stocké vrai vrai vrai de vrai
lac la notion de borderless on en
parlait même pas non c'est bien c'est
bien sa part temps de lire donc là je
glisse gd dérouille bim bim bam est là
qu est ce que je vois netflix existait
déjà
je pensais passer ton compte elle est en
comptait bien on se connecte avoir bien
regardé des versions lorsqu'on sait que
le derby lens en france versus passé
tout premier ipad sortie en 2010 en 2010
c'est beau c'est beau hockey alors la
particularité de ce premier ipad c'est
quoi par rapport à ce qu'on connaît
écoute déjà c'est comment il est arrivé
parce que quand les gens ont su ont vu
la non si l'on dit ça c'est un gros
iphone tulle et quand ça ne marchera
jamais jamais et steve hill avait fait
tout ce qui était bon lui est tout
content sont produits avec les
journalistes
même moi même manger bien c'est un gros
ipad qu'est ce que je vais en faire le
corps mais quand tu l'achète et quand tu
mets tes doigts dessus tu te dis waouh
il ya un intérêt il ya intérêt mais
c'est juste en gros la taille de l'écran
qui permet de trouver une utilité à ce
produit parce que c'est vrai qu'en
termes de navigation en termes d'utilité
on retrouve sensiblement la même chose
que maria tueur d'iphone une nouvelle
gamme une gamme que tu vas que tu vas
pouvoir prendre sur ton canapé
toi tu peux prendre ton portable sur ton
canapé mais c'est pas la même ergonomie
c'est là une taie un truc que tu veux
passer à tes enfants donc il a vu juste
ouais il a vu vraiment juste c'est vrai
mais je compte me l'écran franchement
regarde l'écran
niveau couleurs machin truc je trouve
qu'on est non-voyant densité unique
celle ça je suis d'accord on s'est bien
améliorée avec mes luminosité tout ça on
est bien on est bien dans les biens
durables et la ligue et sur internet tu
pouvais faire tout ce que tu voulais et
y avait bien sûr des versions cellulaire
comme celle ci oui mais ça sérieusement
cellulaire
cette version c'est une version
sèchement rappelé les relations
cellulaire il y avait la version wifi
exactement d'accord enfin les deux
étaient wifi mais il y avait une cave l
aube sans cellulaire en plus il a payé
avec lorie est les plus chers 1 700
dollars de puissants mais c'est plus
cher très cher d'accord ok cool et
l'ipad a eu un succès bon succès dans
les premières versions
mais comme c'est un appareil qui
vieillit très très bien et qui a d une
évolution qui sont pas non plus énorme
comme avec les téléphones ont cas libyen
il ya une perte de vitesse
c'est vrai au niveau 2 au niveau des
ventes d'accord c'est à dire que le port
l'ordinateur portable à un
renouvellement plus en renouveler plus
tôt son ordinateur portable parce que
niveau puissance mais c'est avec la il
ya un moment on arrivé à un stade de
puissance de pélissanne ipad et ipad 2
tous les iphone r était hyper puissant
et c'est vrai que ce sont ces
produits-là tuyaux renouer parce que tes
applications
tu peux pas faire sonner les dernières
mises à jour sur ta bécane voilà du coup
si tu veux profiter de la dernière
action de l'application ou d'autres
fonctionnalités tu es obligé de changer
ton produit c'est là où c'est
effectivement un peu le cercle le côté
un peu vicieux du produit mais c'est
vrai que sinon moi georges 1,2 à la
maison qui fonctionne plutôt pas mal
mais déjà ce qui est problématique
retrouvé deux mois à nouveau une ipad 2
c'est lorsque tu étais mise à jour 3 des
comptes qu'à une certaine mise à jour ça
commençait déjà un peu ramé alors si tu
voi c'est sûrement sur la version
d'origine
on doit juste les quelques correctifs
qui pourrait proposer des machines elle
traversé le temps s'est facilement voilà
l'histoire passe à coups de gueule parce
qu'il faut quand même passer l'écueil du
val de ruz 1 alors qu'est ce que tu as
d'autres c'est un cadeau ça donne ça
madame non donc s'il vous plaît qu'à les
assistants bas c'est pour de vrai sur
leboncoin j'allais me semble qu'au club
assez pour les machos alors que pas du
tout on est toujours en 2010 un
téléphone que j'ai beaucoup aimé pour ma
part je sais pas si tu l'a beaucoup aimé
c'est l'iphone numéro 4 j'ai eu le cas
pour tuer le quatrième quart moi j'ai
bien kiffé parce que ça a été
on était passé sur le plastique des 3g
3gs on est retourné donc enfin on a même
démocratiser un peu le vert +2 order et
le métal autour ce qui se fait beaucoup
maintenant
j'allais dire parce que tu vois très
bien qu'avec l'iphone dit c'est ce que
tu retrouves c'est un peu cette base
elle la base était là tout était déjà là
lors verte n'était pas déjà là mais
effectivement le dos en verre étaient là
les fameuses traces de doigts et déjà à
l'époque on va pas se mentir le côté
hyper précieux était là non
effectivement ça c'est un beau produit
raconte une belle histoire se produit
donc a très bien commencé à marcher mais
il y a eu un petit problème de
conception
c'est ballot c'est ballot qui s'appelait
l'antennagate d'accord alors on a eu les
iphone qui se plie on a eu des problèmes
de batterie dernièrement mais celui ci
l'avait un problème d'antenne ce petit
coquin ça veut dire que si on le prenait
de la main droite
pas de soucis face qui est un petit peu
d'écartement là tu vas entre le problème
se situe ici sur la partie d'énergie
smart phone
c'est l'antenne qui est là donc
d'accord ici pas trop de problèmes et la
recontre de la main gauche et comme
souvent on prend de la main gauche pour
taper de la droite
il suffisait que tu appuies un peu fort
ici et tu perdais jusqu'à trois barres
de signal
le programme raison c'est énorme donc en
gros tu as un smartphone dès que tu m'as
envoyé un message qui ne capte plus
voilà et qui coûte cher je pense qu'on
était dans les jeux pendant l'émission
droit quand même à l'époque joli cadeau
d'accord donc séance de crise chez apple
peut alors se dit pas ils ont des ils
ont des salles pour tester les antennes
c'est un tulle ils ont montré les images
après un truc de fou conférence de
presse exceptionnelle par steve jobs sur
scène mes chers amis il a démontré que
plein d'autres téléphones avaient elles
aussi ce problème grave encore il va
sans dire
on est un peu couillon on n'est pas les
seuls on est prêt ça voilà je passe d'un
petit mot calmer tout le monde mais bon
on regarde non ça un peu calmé la presse
mais c'est que ça fait beaucoup couler
beaucoup d'encre et chose assez
incroyable ils ont offert un jumper à
chaque utilisateur bon c'était sur aile
de raie limité à faut pas rêver non plus
à chaque utilisateur un bumper gratuit
d'accord ou un bumper qui pouvait aller
jusqu'à 15 $ un truc comme ceci donc
vous pouvez acheter et vous faisait
rembourser par apple ou alors carrément
le remboursement de l'appareil
d'accord donc ça j'ai trouvé correct
parce qu'on va jusqu'au remboursement de
l'appareil si tu n'es pas content il est
fermé je peux vraiment même population
alors j'aime bien me poser non mais là
la rencontre il a perdu toute sa valeur
jamais c'est pas grave
pas grave nous avons donc on a eu peur
on a un bon pour la semaine peur ils
servent à quoi techniquement parce que
c'est sa rampe à spine en tête est
d'accord avec moi
voilà qu'est ce qu'on veut avec ce bonne
place si tu veux le problème c'est que
là tu faisais frein avec la snecma l'eau
qu'elle signe avec ta main d'accord donc
là impossible de bloquer le signal
il a mis en garde tout le monde rigole
tellement c'est le suisse
non plaît je ne sais pas je vais pas
donc ça donc là tu mettes bonne peu
retour donc vraiment la forme de ton
smartphone l'ecab le mans et alors
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est quoi le
truc prix parce que tu vas ci-dessus
excuse moi mais si tu le prends et tu le
prends comme ça tu sers encore tu as là
le signal passe le sénat ba le signal
passe et un souci tu bloques pas ne boit
pas d'accord c'est pour ça que sur les
iphone cellulaire il y avait une partie
en plastique en eau pour les c'est
justement passé de signal d'accord ok tu
comprends c'était très moche
moins chaud et c'était très moche dans
l'aluminium et à une partie roque était
une tentative d'accord mais ça n'est ce
pas cette ligne est donc cette [ __ ] si
tu veux lowe's le sida m'a passé par là
il va il va réussir à passer l'hiver
paye pas pour être beauté pas moche avec
le bumper c'est pas moche mais quand
même parce mais surtout on paye pas ce
design s'est pas très bien passé tu
payes pas ce design parce que tu payes
un truc avec un contour en métal on
retrouve achement premium et qui se
démarque ou qui se démarquent par
rapport à la concurrence et notamment
l'époque parce qu'effectivement c'était
y'a pas si longtemps que ça mais malgré
tout il ya tellement d'évolution
rapidement tu te retrouves avec un truc
pas une excuse moi avec un brin
plastique je crois fondamentalement bon
c'est quand même une crise de confiance
avec apple c'est à dire qu'ils te vivant
un problème en une solution par contre
la solution c soit voulu acheter soit
vous ou l'autre on vous l'offre mais si
on vous l'offre
on rend votre téléphone moche les grecs
- ouais nan ça a été un sacré sacré
problème
après je te dirais que en utilisation
normale sans a fait comme halal problème
est d'accord moi j'en avais un cadre
jamais eu de souligner ans mais c'est
vrai que quand apple fait petite bourde
c'est monumental c'est comme quand il ya
une photo d'un iphone qui sera en avance
et planétaire je veux dire y'a aucune
marque qui crée un buzz bahreïn aucun
blessé et je pense que se posent a même
fait bon vivre
vous avez raison mais sedan par
exactement il ne serait plus là
aujourd'hui si c'est antennagate avait
fait un fiasco absolument est-ce que
celle est ce qu'on va conclure pour
aujourd'hui
écoute
je crois qu'il entend déjà assez vus ils
ont déjà des petites années de crise
hot shots écoute merci beaucoup
l'histoire perrier j'aimerais bien
qu'ils me donnent up quelque chose un
mot de la fin qui me fasse réalité ont
voyagé alors écoutez n'hésitez pas à
venir en suisse
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner bien sûr un
monsieur grue en premier mais pendant
que vous êtes déjà abonné donc c'est
très fort ça il sait pas forcément il ne
faut pas prendre sur youtube seront que
les abonnés qui nous regardent listant
perrier-david économe ramka soutenez les
petits soutenait les pratiques
népotiques puisque pour elle pour être
grand il faut d'abord et petits bravo je
crois que là tu as dit on peut pas aller
plus loin au niveau de la profondeur à
gazon merci beaucoup merci mr tarrier
bah écoute merci de m'avoir accueilli
ans celui-ci c'est très long d'une
rencontre directe en vélo il ya pas trop
d'accord sa géante et jaune avec mon
vélo donc maintenant on va les manger de
la gruyère du de l'amour un gala de
l'agglo et rennes c'est formidable à
grossir merci beaucoup mr perrier
d'avoir accueilli dans son antre avec
toute cette jolie collection que vous ne
voyez pas qui est derrière mais
peut-être qu'un jour c'est pour ça que
vous abonner sa chaîne parce que ici
c'est un musée c'est un musée merci mr
fériés merci à toi merci à tous comme
d'habitude je vous invite à laisser des
jolies pousse à vous abonner à tous
marqué en commentaire et un pareil vous
de votre histoire avec un peu parce que
je sais que vous êtes nombreux à voir
une histoire très intime avec apple
parlez-moi de vos objets par imad vos
iphone de aux ipad de vos mac dites moi
ce que vous avez eu également sur tout
ce que vous voudriez avoir parce que
c'est très intéressant
vous marquez tout sans commentaire comme
d'habitude vous invite à rester
connectés à vous abonner parce qu'on va
parler toujours plus toujours mieux les
trucs un petit peu dingue a toujours au
niveau de la itech ce téléphonie des
smartphones de la robotique toucy de
tout ça encore avec moi il faut il faut
il faut merci beaucoup à bientôt
n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs
je vous embrasse ciao